Vsauce! Kevin here. Tellspec is a new scanner
that will tell you exactly what's in your
food. The company claims their spectrometer
technology will give you a breakdown of the
chemical makeup of food including allergens
or pesticides and will also give you calorie
and fat information. All by shooting a laser
and sending the data of the refracted light
to servers that analyze it and produce the
results on a smart device.
Cornell Creative Machines Lab is developing
a 3D food printer that uses edible inks and
electronic blueprints. They've printed a space
shuttle scallop nugget and cakes with hidden
messages inside - and have created new printing
techniques to add texture called squiggle
printing. Meanwhile, these designs for digital
gastronomy including a chocolatier to make
your own custom chocolate candies.
To help perfect growing your own herbs or
vegetables there's Parrot Flower Power - a
sensor that monitors sunlight, air temperature,
and soil moisture. It connects to a smart
device and its database of over 7,000 plants
helps you maintain the perfect conditions
for healthy growth.
HAPIfork is designed to slow down eating to
help users lose weight. The electronic fork
vibrates when you're eating too fast and monitors
your eating habits including how long your
meals last, how many bites you take and allows
you to set goals to follow your progress after
each meal.
The Kitchen Safe is a time lock container
to help people curb their cravings. Place
junk food or other items you want to avoid
inside, set the timer and be locked out without
any way of getting inside until the timer
goes off.
As part of their 2020 innovations initiative,
Whirlpool unveiled this interactive cooktop
concept. It uses an induction surface and
augmented reality to combine social media
with a dynamic stove top. And the time and
temperature of the virtual burners automatically
adjust when you place a pot or pan depending
upon the recipe you've selected.
The iGrill is a wireless smart thermometer
that tells you when your meat is perfectly
cooked. It connects to a smart device and
allows you to select presets depending on
the type of meat and how you like it cooked
- and then it simply alerts you when it's
ready.
Refrigerated watermelon stroller!
The Electroxlux Design Lab has introduced
some incredible new kitchen concepts includingKitchen
Hub to manage your food, help you eat healthier
and avoid food waste. The augmented reality
smart ring can store and monitor individual
diets, offer recipes with the food you have
and allowing you to shop online to instantly
order things you don't.
Global Chef is a social kitchen appliance
concept that uses laser holograms to bring
people together. The idea is not only to be
able to cook with distant friends and family
but also take cooking lessons from top chefs.
Home 2025 is GE's realistic vision of future
home appliances and includes a compact, window-mounted
urban grill, a smart faucet that tells you
how hydrated you are, and a food disposal
that compresses food scraps into compost pellets.
So 3D print some food with your hologram chef
and lock your homegrown vegetables in a kitchen
safe to eat later with your smart fork. And
as always - thanks for watching.